in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Alexis
from Cheyenne Wyoming is with us hey how
are ya hey Dave I am truly better than I
deserve
cool welcome how can I help Thanks so
I'm wondering after you're completely
debt-free how do you determine what a
reasonable amount of money is to spend
on fun things like vacations upgrading
cars and eating out that kind of thing
cool
well you there's three things you can do
with money you can give it you can
invest it and you can spend it once
you're a hundred percent debt-free and
you're in baby steps three four five
right up in there you're investing money
and you're you know you got your
emergency fund in place until you have
your emergency fund in place and you're
debt-free other than your home you need
to really focus on those things well
once you're there which is kind of what
you're asking then how do we balance out
the investing the giving and the fund
and the problem is there's always a
limiting factor meaning the more you
give the less you've got to invest the
more you spend the less you got - givers
invest right
these are anytime you take from one of
these buckets I mean you take too much
from all these buckets it limits the
other bucket so to do zero of any of
those three is a bad idea
zero giving zero investing or zero fund
once you're after baby step three so you
want to have some of each and then you
just start asking yourself your question
and there's not a wrong answer really is
which of these do I want to do more of
the more fun you have the stuff you're
talking about the less you're going to
be able to invest and the less fun
you're going to build to have later
because you're not going to have as much
money you know and so and the more you
give the less you're gonna have to
invest and the more fun you have the
less you have to give which is more fun
really but that's kind of but so I think
you just do that you sit down and look
at it we look at it around our house on
ratios and so we say if we've got a
thousand dollars laying here how much
percentage of that do we want to live
spend on fun what percentage do we want
to give and what percentage do we want
to invest
and you know a baby step four I got
you're putting fifteen percent into
investments right yes if you've heard
the baby steps so that one's kind of
locked in anything above that can go
towards either paying off the house
early or increase giving or increased
fund and those kinds of things but let's
just say you are driving a horrible old
beater that's got five hundred million
miles on it you just finished your baby
step three you're probably not going to
start investing for a few minutes you're
probably going to get save up and get
you a little better car it's time to do
that or you got a couch with a spring
sticking through it you know that kind
of thing
you probably need to stop and buy you a
couch right then once you get past maybe
step three but if you just keep spending
everything you're going to retire broke
and you're never going to give so you're
gonna retire broke and bitter because
people that don't give end up bitter so
you just got to be touching all three
bases over the scope of time sometimes
for a period of time I'm heavy on
investing or I'm heavy on fun or I'm
heavy on giving and then I may come back
and but I always I'm doing something in
all three of those buckets as we go past
baby step three and you just got to
gauge it and say you know I can do this
this one time I'm gonna stop get this
car bought I need a buy a car or I want
to buy a better car either ones fine one
or need but then next year I'm going to
concentrate on investing and by the time
I get to Christmas I'm gonna do some big
giving all the time I get to Christmas
and you just start working that into
your budget and your plan and and so
that you keep all three things in your
sights but you kind of let one common
one go and another one coming another
one go and just kind of keep moving them
around but if you'll keep the investing
going steady at at least fifteen percent
you'll become a millionaire and then
that opens up the ability to live off of
your investments and really really do
some very cool things with giving and
fun both along this path the
millionaires that we study they have fun
they go on vacation they buy cars they
just don't buy a brand-new sixty
thousand dollar car right by I used
twenty thousand dollar car you know and
something they pay cash for it and they
don't run up their credit cards being
irresponsible and impulsive you know
they don't have any credit card debt and
and so that gives them the room to
continue to invest
see what I'm saying so it's it's sum of
everything sum of everything all the
time is that logical does that what is
your particular thing you're wanting to
buy so we're wanting to go on vacation
and spend about $4,000 later this year
okay and then my husband also wants to
update his truck so we want to put about
an additional 20,000 on top of his you
know maybe step three or beyond
we're on baby step six six okay yeah so
you're putting 15% in yes and above that
you got the money to do these other
things yes sir we do do thank you
that's exactly what I'm talking about
that fits in with the conversation we
were just having absolutely okay perfect
well done what do you guys do for a
living we're both active duty military
oh cool which branch Air Force oh wow
well thank you for your service thank
you Dave all right cool I'm glad you're
winning baby step six or good for you
awesome
well done